Allen un neuf un un où sont vos
agents d'urgence seront là d'une
seconde à l'autre il redescendra
Leia, peu importe qui c'est, je vous suggère de quitter
cette maison avant de faire quoi que ce soit, vous
allez regretter que
ce soit déjà fait,
cela marque la sixième fille assassinée, les
enquêteurs croient qu'ils  j'ai affaire
à un tueur en série, je serai là quand
tu en auras besoin, d'accord, je rentre chez moi
maintenant, je t'aime aussi, au revoir
et où sont tes médecins d'urgence, le
nouvel emplacement est un nouveau
jetable pas cher, ok, ok, pour qu'on t'aide, j'ai
besoin de toi.  pour m'aider, nous allons nous battre,
peux-tu lui dire que tu es sur une autoroute ou une
autoroute de surface, ok, donne un coup de pied
au feu arrière, c'est du bon travail, je veux
voir si une autre voiture pourra le
remarquer, tu sais, trouve un  levier de déverrouillage
ouvre la porte maintenant
écoute-moi ne fais pas de mal à cette petite
fille tu n'es pas obligé de faire ça
c'est déjà fait c'est déjà fait c'est
le même homme on va te trouver
où est dehors
où est ton urgence